Roger is on the line in Colorado
Roger welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey thank you for taking my call
sure what's up I've got a two-part
question regarding tithing the first
part is I give help out a relative with
a couple hundred bucks every month can
that be considered tithing and then the
second part is I'm not associated with a
church so instead could I do
two for example st. Jude you certainly
can give to anyone and that's certainly
a wonderful thing to do outrageous
generosity is the hallmark of people who
build wealth and enjoy wealth and have
the best mental health around their
wealth wealth doesn't become a toxic
thing and so outrageous generosity is
always encouraged the word tithe
typically is applying to a biblical
situation and it's it the word in Hebrew
when you look it up in Hebrew and an Old
Testament literally means tenth one
tenth of your income and the primary
people that discuss tithing from a
religious standpoint from a biblical
standpoint would be Orthodox Jewish and
evangelical Christians not even all
evangelical Christians but the vast
majority of evangelical Christians teach
to give a tenth of your income to your
local church and because the local
church represents the Old Testament
storehouse which took care of the
Levites the pastoral tribe of Israel
took care of the pastors and took care
of the widows and the orphans and the
local church is supposed to do that and
a lot of times does does a great job at
that and so as an evangelical Christian
I give a tenth of my net income not net
of taxes but my net profits from our
business and for many other sources of
income to my local church now it sounds
like you're not involved in a local
church and so it may not have to do with
your faith walk it just may have more to
do with generosity so
it's just a matter of a technical
definition of the term you know so if
you say hey right because I'm not
involved I'm still gonna give 10% of my
income that's fine you could give 11% of
your income you could give 8 percent of
your income
it's fine but the definition of a tithe
is local church local synagogue if
you're a Jewish and it's a tenth of your
income now again it's okay
whatever you do outrageous generosity is
a wonderful thing and it is building
your character and turning you into a
better human every day that you do it
which is why those of us that are people
of faith have have it as a part of the
rhythm of our life we want it to be
spiritual experience to grow us and you
know that's not gonna change with you
it's just the the format is going to
change does that make sense
yes so much yeah so you can give
whatever you want to give there's no
limitation on it but again it's just a
technical definition is that okay yep
thank you for the call man we appreciate
you joining us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and four my brothers and sisters in
Christ out there my fellow faith walkers
out there you know you can get real
caught up in the legalistic aspects of
giving sometimes and sometimes you can
get too caught up in not observing some
of the principles of giving as a part of
your faith law Dallas Willard as book
the spirit of the disciplines says the
tithe is one of the spiritual
disciplines of our lives for those of us
that are there are people of faith and
so regular church attending evangelical
Christian you know that kind of a thing
or as I said Orthodox Jewish Christian
Orthodox Jewish same thing so if it's a
part of the rhythm of your life it makes
you into who you're supposed to be and
that's the purpose for it it is not a
thing where you're earning God's favor
he doesn't love tie there's more than
non-tithers he's crazy about all of you
even if you don't think he's there he's
crazy about all of you that's not the
point
and so it's not that you know in a hand
I think you're gonna be hard-pressed to
scripturally prove that you know tithing
causes you
it causes God to give you money that's
not what happens but I tell you what
does happen regardless of whether you're
doing that you know when you give with
the right heart you are a grateful
person a generous person and grateful
and generous people are highly
attractive people they're fun to be
around you want to be with them not
because they're gonna give you stuff I
don't mean that but they're just those
that are the ones that are smiling
they're happy and they have a tendency
to have opportunities come to them for
those reasons because they don't look
like they were weaned on a pickle you
know and then this you know scowl on
their face all the time and so
generosity changes who you are it makes
you more attractive and when you're
attractive you know what that means it
means you attract things and so that's
what ends up happening that's why givers
have a tendency to prosper because
givers have a tendency to be better
people over time rather than selfish
jerks right so this is true for all of
us and and but that those of us that are
people of faith that's it gets sometimes
a toxic spirit over it and everybody's
all twisted up like I had one coach one
financial counselor telling me one time
he would not help someone with their
money problems if they would not tithe
I'm like yeah somehow I don't see God
doing that wait I am NOT going to be
your God unless you tithe it doesn't
it's just nowhere in scripture that says
that none whatsoever
so no I'm just gonna help you I don't
care whether you agree with me I don't
care and I don't put up with people they
don't like me if you're gonna be mad at
me all the time I just block you can't
believe Dave Ramsey so thin-skinned he
blocks everybody on Twitter it's not
thin-skinned it's just if you hate me
what's your point you're too stupid to
not follow me I can help you with that
block you know that's what amounts to so
you know if you don't want to do this
stuff
okay you don't have to do it I'm not
gonna make you do it but it's not you
know so you just kind of get in there
and figure out all right
what's a toxic view of this and what's a
proper wise kind generous grateful view
of this really good question thank you
for joining us